almacena a la luz de las velas en un
acto más de Rebeldía que de amor así
sortean estos ucranianos la escasez de
Electricidad consecuencia de los
constantes ataques rusos contra las
instalaciones eléctricas que ya han
dejado a más de un millón de hogares sin
su ministro
nos endurece más ha habido un corte de
luz pero ayuda a nuestro Ucrania
ahorraremos energía y aparte de eso
puedes sentir el ambiente es muy
romántico la gente se sienta con velas
crea un gran ambiente Así que creo que
los rusos No tendrán éxito somos muy
fuertes espíritus esto significa que
nadie ni nada puede doblegarnos
mientras que en nikolaife cerca de la
reñida región de gerson los residentes
cargan con botellas de agua desde los
puntos de distribución luego de casi un
mes sin agua potable en los hogares
debido a los daños de las cañerías
como resultado de las acciones de
combate Se dañó el sistema de agua que
suministraba a nikolaifa agua potable
del río niéper tomamos de nieve en el
territorio de la región de gerson el
agua potable era transportada a nicolae
por dos tuberías de 1400 milímetros cada
una las 24 horas del día
las autoridades iniciaron la descarga de
Agua de la central hidroeléctrica de
Novak a tiempo que desaloja la población
civil de las áreas cercanas a La
amenazada Represa para minimizar el
desastre que causarían posibles daños en
su infraestructura cuando Ucrania acusa
a Rusia de querer volarla y kiev
advierte de un nuevo tsunami migratorio
durante el invierno hacia los países
vecinos europeos por los graves daños en
su infraestructura eléctrica